acabo de comerme un pavo enorme el cual
me dio muchas energías para hacer más de
estos vídeos de ese arte y entonces me
siento bastante animado porque además
del gran pago que me acabo de comer y
bueno no está de más de 7 que es día de
gracias y por eso fue que estaba tan
emocionado por comer el pavo de día de
gracias además de esto estoy muy
emocionado porque estoy empezando una
nueva sección estamos en este vídeo en
la sección número 9 del examen número 2
que por cierto está en la página 47 de
la guía oficial de estudio de ese tema y
vamos con el primer problema a ver qué
nos dice el primer problema en un
autobús escolar hay la misma cantidad de
niñas que de niños cuando el camión
parte de la escuela am así que vamos a
poner esto como si fueran hombres y
mujeres
a hombres es igual a mujeres cuando el
camión sale de la escuela tenemos la
misma cantidad de líneas que de niños en
la primera parada cuatro niños salen del
autobús y nadie entra entonces vamos a
ponerlo así en la primera
parada en la primera parada salen cuatro
niños entonces menos cuatro hombres
menos cuatro hombres y nadie entra y
después dice después de la primera
parada quedan el doble de niñas que de
niños en el autobús salen cuatro hombres
y después nos fijamos en la cantidad de
niños que hay adentro del autobús y
ahora resulta que la cantidad de mujeres
es dos veces la cantidad de hombres que
quedan pero cuántos hombres quedan bueno
si empezamos con ocho hombres y después
salieron cuatro entonces quedan h menos
cuatro
y aquí para que no se confunda voy a
poner que son menos cuatro hombres menos
cuatro niños más bien ni los gay
perfecto son pequeños hombrecitos y
bueno lo que me preguntan es cuántas
líneas hay en el autobús y esto de una
manera hebraicas l muy fácil aunque si
tú usas la lógica también estoy seguro
que estás al día porque es un problema
que tiene mucho sentido común mucha
intuición pero a ver vamos a ver qué
dice en un principio teníamos la misma
cantidad de hombres y de mujeres en la
primera parada salen cuatro hombres
entonces salieron cuatro hombres nadie
entró y después vemos cuántos hombres y
mujeres quedan en el autobús y nos damos
cuenta que la cantidad de días que
quedan es el doble de la cantidad de
hombres que quedan en ese momento esto
es muy importante no es el doble de la
cantidad de hombres que había
inicialmente sino del doble de la
cantidad de niños que quedan en ese
momento fíjate bien si nosotros te
empezamos con h niños y salieron cuatro
niños entonces en ese momento hay y
menos cuatro niños y bueno si esto lo
quisiéramos resolver de una manera
matemática date cuenta que aquí tenemos
a emen aquí tenemos a m y entonces m es
igual a m por lo tanto h es igual a 2
por h menos 4
esta m es igual a esta m entonces h es
igual a 2 por h menos 4 y de aquí se
distribuye este 2 no queda 2 por este 2
por este entonces voy a obtener que h es
igual a dos veces h menos 8 y ahora si
yo restó h de ambos lados de esta
ecuación voy a ponerlo con este color si
yo restó h de este lado y restó h de
este lado y de este lado sumó 8 y de
este lado sumó 8 entonces a que voy a
llegar este 8 con este 8 se van esta h
con esta de semana y me quedan que 2 h -
h es lo mismo que h
esto es igual a 8 positivo 2 h sánchez h
y aquí me queda 8 es decir que la
cantidad de niños que había inicialmente
son 88 niños y si inicialmente había la
misma cantidad de niños que de niñas
entonces la cantidad de niñas que había
en un inicio eran 8 niñas y ya está
era justo lo que me preguntaban cuál es
la cantidad de niñas que había en él en
el autobús y bueno también podría
resolver este mismo problema de una
manera muy intuitiva si tú te
preguntabas
tengo que al principio había la misma
cantidad de niños que de niñas y después
bajaron 4 y quedan la mitad de niños que
los que estaban en un principio a ver
qué número si lo multiplicó por 2 es
igual a ese número más 4 y bueno pues
ese número es
444 es 8 4 por 2 es 8 y por lo tanto la
respuesta correcta era 8 niños y 8
líneas ya está aquí está el problema
número uno y bueno vamos a hacer el
problema número dos y el problema número
dos me dice lo siguiente
cuál de las siguientes gráficas es la
representación de una función lineal que
tenga pendiente negativa y una
intersección con el eje de las 10
positivo y bueno no te voy a poner aquí
todas las opciones mejor vamos a poner
la opción que cumpla eso aunque se vea
más o menos de ese estilo así que déjame
hacerte aquí mi eje x
muy bien aquí me quedé hay es
perfecto este es el eje james este es el
eje y este es el eje x y bueno cuando
hablo de una función lineal en lo que
estoy pensando realmente es en una recta
todas las funciones lineales son rectas
entonces lo que queremos es una recta
que cumplan que tenga pendiente negativa
es decir que vaya hacia abajo que cuando
nos movamos a la derecha nos movamos
hacia abajo es una pendiente negativa
es decir en un cambio positivo de x
vamos a tener un cambio negativo de
james y por otra parte intersecte al eje
de las 10 en un número positivo es decir
interesante decir a 10 en algún punto de
estos y bueno hay un montón de rectas
que cumplen estas dos situaciones y
todas se ven más o menos así va a
interceptar el eje
en un punto positivo va a tener una
pendiente negativa y entonces se ven más
o menos así y de hecho la única recta de
estos incisos que se ve así es el inciso
de todos los demás se ven como rectas
muy distintas a esta que tenga pendiente
negativa intercepta el eje de las 10 en
un número positivo ya están así que
vamos a movernos al problema número 3
eso estuvo muy fácil y vamos ser el
problema número 3 ahora le está genial
para el próximo número 3 y para el
problema número 4 necesitamos esta misma
tabla así que la voy a hacer es una
tabla pequeña tenemos una tabla parecida
a ésta y está hablando de donas
está hablando de la cantidad de donas de
donas con respecto al precio entonces el
precio y bueno dice que una dona una
dona vale 40 centavos vale
0.40 centavos
por otra parte seis donas valen un peso
con 89 centavos un peso con 89 centavos
y 12 donas 12 donas valen 3 pesos con 59
centavos 3 pesos con 59 centavos es lo
que valen 12 donas y la pregunta número
3 me dice cuál es la mejor aproximación
de estos incisos y no voy a escribir los
incisos es mejor que lo hagamos manual
cuál es la mejor aproximación al precio
de una dona si compro la caja de 6 donas
es decir voy a comprar esta caja de aquí
y yo lo que quiero saber es cuál es la
aproximación al precio unitario de las
donas si compro la caja de 6 donas y
bueno pues esencialmente lo que hay que
hacer es dividir
1.89
entre 6 y cuantos esto bueno pues esto
es
0.3 3.6 18 y aquí sobran 0 bajaremos el
9 y me queda 11 por 6 y 6 para 9 son 3
bajamos un 0 y después sigue un 5 es
decir que el precio unitario de cada una
de las donas en la caja de 6 es de
0.3 cientos 15 pesos y bueno lo que más
aproxima es el inciso pvem el inciso b
me dice
0.31 entonces ya está es el inciso b y
vamos a resolver el problema 4 que
también tiene que ver con esta tabla
entonces lo voy a poner aquí entonces lo
voy a poner aquí el problema 4 me dice
lo siguiente
cuál va a ser el precio exacto cuál va a
ser el precio exacto si queremos comprar
21 donas 21 donas cuánto vamos a pagar y
bueno si te das cuenta no hay ninguna
caja de 21 donas y tampoco en ninguna
trampa porque si tú compras dos paquetes
de 12 son 24 donas y estoy seguro que te
va a salir mucho más barato que si tú
compras 21 donas pero realmente lo que
quieren es el precio exacto de 21 donas
entonces para conseguir este precio qué
te parece si vamos sumando poco a poco
estas cantidades y vamos sumando la
cantidad de donas hasta llegar a 21
sería bueno comprar primero una caja de
12 donas entonces vamos a comprar una
caja de 12 donas una caja de 12 donas
uno por 12 donas y esto valen 3 pesos
con 59 3 pesos con 59 después a 12 6 es
18 y más 62 en 1
vamos a comprar otra caja de 6 donas
entonces van 12 + 6 son 18 donas y una
caja de seis donas valen un peso con 89
un peso con 89 y por último van 18 y yo
quiero llegar a 21 me faltan 3 voy a
comprar 3 zonas individuales es decir 3
por una dona voy a comprar 3 zonas pero
cada una de ellas vale 40 centavos
entonces 40 centavos por 3 es un peso
con 20 centavos un peso con 20 centavos
ya ver si voy a hacer la suma de todo
esto vamos a sumar y me quedan 99
18 y llevamos una
y 5 son 6 6 y 8 son 14 14 y 2 son 16 y
llevamos una y después me quedan uno más
uno más uno son tres más tres son 66
pesos con 68 centavos es lo que me va a
costar exactamente 21 donas si no quiero
comprar 24 ni nada raro así que aquí
está el problema número 3 ya tenemos el
problema número 4 estaban muy sencillos
así que vamos a hacer el problema número
5 déjeme borrar esto y todavía tengo
tiempo para hacer el último problema el
problema número 5 y tiene una gráfica
muy parecida a la siguiente déjame
hacerte esta gráfica tengo aquí el eje
de las x por aquí tengo al eje de las x
este perdón es el eje de la yes entonces
este es el eje de leyes por aquí tengo
al eje de las x y tengo una función muy
parecida a ésta y vamos a poner la
escala que me dan aquí tengo al 2 por
aquí tengo al 4 por aquí tengo 6 por
aquí tengo al 2 por aquí tengo al 4 por
aquí tengo al 6 y por aquí tengo al
menos 2 y sigue y sigue y sigue y luego
voy a utilizar esto para hacer mi
gráfica mi gráfica se ve más o menos así
tengo algo que va por aquí llega como a
este punto más o menos y de aquí baja
hasta llegar como a este punto
más o menos y después de aquí vuelve a
subir de tal manera que hace más o menos
esto exacto y lo que me preguntan en
este ejercicio es cuánto vale h de 5 si
esta es la función hdx y bueno
esencialmente no sabemos cuál es la
función así que vamos a fijarnos más o
menos en dónde está el valor de 5 así
que si yo digo que por aquí está el
valor de 5 h de 5 va a ser mi valor por
aquí en mi gráfica dejamos el punteado
me va a quedar algo más o menos así por
aquí debería de estar h de 5 y bueno eso
en mi eje llega a dónde vamos a parar me
voy por acá me voy por acá por la carne
voy por acá me voy por acá me voy por
acá voy por acá y llego como por aquí y
si yo quiero el valor más cercano a hd 5
que es lo que me preguntan el valor más
cercano a 5 pues esto es cercano a 3
aquí parece que estamos más cerca de 4
pero realmente si tú ves la gráfica de
este libro se parece mucho o se acerca
mucho a 3 así que vamos a decir que hd 5
es 3 y ya se me acabó el tiempo no tengo
tiempo para hacer otro problema pero le
seguimos en el siguiente vídeo nos vemos
en el siguiente